[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul
aka the guy who always goes in deep when
it comes to the boys
there's gonna be massive spoilers here
for the run so if you haven't had a
chance to check it out yet then scram
caboose get the get the heckins out of
here you heard or i'll
i'll make you watch your watch mojo
video or something anyway
after rereading the comic series
recently the ending
made me remember something a truth i'd
long since forgotten
one i'd buried in my mind because of how
much it altered my perception of one key
character
and that is because in the comics billy
butcher
was actually the final villain of the
storyline
since reading it many years ago i'd
simply repressed this memory
and accepted the real ending as being
the reveal that black noir was actually
a clone of homelander
and that both died in the final arc
probably probably not the best person to
be doing a breakdown on the boys but
here now so sit back and shut the hell
up anyway the book goes far beyond this
and the final chapter that follows it
titled the bloody doors off
culminates with butcher revealing his
true plan now in case you haven't read
it the story itself begins with butcher
basically giving the boys some time off
after all they've been through
however what the character is actually
doing is that he's getting them out the
way so that he can tie up all the loose
ends before enacting his final plan
which is to wipe out all soups on earth
early on in the comics we witnessed that
there's a variation of compound v
that causes people's heads to explode
and butcher manages to engineer this so
that he can take them all down at once
he kills mallory loves sausage mothers
milk
frenchie and the female before traveling
to the top of the empire state building
where he plans to set things off huey
arrives and the pair talk back and forth
before huey runs towards him misses and
goes through a window
butcher catches him and the pair fall
over the side and land on a lower
platform which is where billy breaks his
neck and hughie gets badly injured
they both lie there and billy admits
that he kept huey around
because he needed someone to balance him
out someone with some humanity that
would stop him
should it come down to it billy is
crippled and he wants huey to kill him
but he won't
thus the former lies about murdering his
parents
and this sends huey into a rage which
finally makes him do it
now there are obviously a lot more
nuances to it than that but that's the
basics of it so we can understand how
the show
may be heading in a similar direction
now i'm really unsure
whether the tv show will actually follow
this arc and after throwing a poll
online the other day for people who'd
read the work
an overwhelming 68 of you didn't think
that the series would follow the same
story as the comics
it was probably the the most important
vote of this week and
they they people voted
it's more than kanye got i suppose
anyway i've been thinking about it for a
while and i actually think that there
are
some clues in the show that hint towards
it actually taking this path and that we
will get butcher as the true villain in
the end
now in order to discuss how this all
lines up properly
we have to travel back to butch's
childhood and how there are several
similarities to how it's portrayed in
the comics
in this source material butcher's father
is a very violent man
and in the area that they live he has
the reputation of a hard case
in addition to this he brutally beats
billy's mother
doing it loud enough so that he and his
brother lenny can hear it
because they're children they're
powerless to stop any of it
and it even gets to the point that their
mother has to have a glass eye
because their dad shatters her eye
socket butcher stays awake at night
listening to it going on and he gets
angrier and angrier to the point that he
obsesses
over beating his dad to death however
what holds him back from doing anything
is his brother lenny who pretty much
stops him because he doesn't want his
mother to have a murdered husband
and a son in jail now we know that some
of these scenarios
likely happen to the billy that we've
seen in the show as
both versions hate their dad and we know
that lenny was also instrumental in
keeping them
cool in both versions of the story lenny
also dies which we'll get into
in just a bit however where things
differ is that in the comics
billy and lenny managed to convince
their mother to leave their father
this idea is pretty much spurred on by
becky butch's wife
who tells her that she doesn't have to
put up with it anymore
yes i know she's called becca in the
show yeah so so stop
stop typing now now the show has billy's
mother stay with his father
and we meet them when the characters
come face to face whereas
in the original work their relationship
is shown in flashbacks
now though this differs a fair bit we do
have this motif of billy basically being
beaten by his father
and the idea that this caused him to
become the hardest man alive
that's in english saying yeah and i know
what hard can also mean anyway
we get a glimpse into the characters
psychology in the comics
and learn that though billy hated him in
many respects he became him
over the years a butcher became more and
more violent
and this aspect of his father's way of
doing things was very much imparted into
the character
this is pretty much one of the main
things that makes him believe that
violence can be defeated with more
violence
and it does tie into the end namely
billy's plan
the reason that belly wants to wipe out
wall soups is because
they killed his wife and though it did
seem like the show was going in a new
direction after the ending of season one
we know that from this point on she will
indeed be dead
thus the motivation is there that could
eventually lead to him becoming the big
bad
now because of the relationship that he
had with lenny in the comics butcher
decides to take
huion as he knows he will keep him from
going off the rails
this is something that we've also had
confirmed in the show and looking back
it seems strange that this was given so
much attention to basically be a minor
plot element in one of the episodes
thus the show could be setting up
something that goes towards the finals
scene in the comics
as the only reason that butcher really
tries to save huey from going over the
edge
is because he's reminded of his
similarity to lenny
thus we have these points that line up
and hints to us that the butcher in the
show
may not be too dissimilar from the one
in the comics huey could indeed be kept
around his stop billy from going too far
and with his wife dead who knows what
the character will do next
now this is where i think the biggest
clue comes in and that is that butcher
actually wanted to kill
all of the remaining supes by blowing
their heads off
this is obviously something that
victoria newman can already do
and we know that her opposite is
actually cindy
a character who was last seen
hitchhiking away from the sage grove
center
if the show is indeed going the route of
the comics then butcher could discover
that vic
is in fact the head popper and he could
decide to track down
cindy in order to return the favor to
the remaining soups themselves
if this was the case then it would give
butcher a way to
actually do something similar to what
his character does in the comics
and cindy is such a wild card that i
could actually see it happening
now though it is unlikely that the show
will continue past the supes
there is definitely a number of key
things that point to butcher being
similar to how he is in the comics
firstly is his past namely the
relationship that he had with his father
second is the relationship that he had
with his brother which we know is
instrumental in why he chose huey to be
part of the group
thirdly is the death of butch's wife
which becomes the main motivation for
why he wants to kill the soups
and finally is how he will carry this
out which is by the exploding heads
which we know has been set up in the
show through cindy and vic
now the only thing that's really
stopping this from playing out is that
the butcher in the show has seen
the better side to the supes through
both ryan and starlight however
who knows how far the character is
willing to go with all that homelander
could potentially unleash
i do think though that all together
there is definitely enough there to hint
that butcher may actually be the big bad
at the end of the boys
and it seems like they're potentially
lining him up that way
whether they do it or not remains to be
seen but hopefully this video has shown
you that all the main pieces are there
in place to pull this off
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on this breakdown and if you think
they're gonna go that way or or a
different one
i'm still not completely sold myself but
i think it's probably the most
interesting way that they could end the
show if you enjoyed this video then
please drop a thumbs up
make sure you check out everything we
know about season three which is going
to be linked at the end
don't forget we're giving away 3 copies
of the marvel phase 2 box set
and all you have to do to be with the
chance of winning is make sure you
subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below the winner is
going to be chosen at random on the 30th
of november
so make sure you get involved if you
want to support the channel and get to
see content early
then please consider clicking the join
button below you can also become
chapters on the discord server linked in
the description
or heavy spoilers on twitter thanks for
making it until the end of the video
you've been the best i've been paul i'll
see you next time take care
[Music]
peace
[Music]
you